[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with columnist at the article ali mirage
and political editor at the sunday
mirror nigel nelson
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
run for your lives as the headline on
the metro alongside a picture of a woman
and child running to take cover amid
shelling in the city of urpin
the sun has the same picture with a
similar headline
the eye also leads on people running
from airstrikes to save their lives
the daily mirror has a picture of a man
escaping bombing with a child with the
words save them
the daily telegraph leads on the prime
minister condemning vladimir putin's
actions as barbaric after civilians
attempting to flee the invasion of
ukraine were killed by russian shells
plea for safe passage reports the
guardian as the second attempt to hold a
ceasefire
fails the daily express also reports on
the failure of the ceasefire calling it
pure evil with no mercy for civilians as
they flee
the daily mail quotes the uk's top
military commander admiral sir tony
radicum who has said vladimir putin
could still lose the war in ukraine
after suffering losses to his forces
and the financial times reports on the
u.s secretary of state anthony blinken
saying that discussions are ongoing with
europe to ban oil imports from russia
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
programme you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we're joined tonight by the
columnist at the article ali muraj and
political editor at the sunday mirror
nigel nelson welcome to you both thanks
for joining us this evening let's start
with the uh financial times as we ran
through there on the the list of papers
uh and this possibility of a ban on oil
imports from russia nigel
well i mean th
this is one of the things they've been
talking about for a while and of course
it's been europe who've
been resisting this
russia is providing 30 35
of uh europe's energy needs
and so there's no question that if you
start stopping russian oil and gas
coming in
uh it's gonna hurt hurt europe quite a
lot but
um it also represents half of all
russia's export revenue
so if sanctions are really going to bite
then we than the rest of us have to bite
the bullet as far as britain is
concerned it shouldn't affect us too
much on the basis that uh we take less
than four percent
of our energy from russia so we wouldn't
be hurt that badly although we probably
see a bit of a rise in in our home
energy bills
but it's important now if we're really
going to try and put the noose around
russia's economy
it is very important this key part of it
is now addressed and we stopped their
supplies coming through
ali this this definitely would step up
the the move in terms of crippling the
russian economy wouldn't it
well i think a lot of measures have
already been taken
so far julian over the last few days the
the huge impact of the exclusion of
certain banks uh from the swift system
including a clam down on the activities
of the russian central bank i mean
they've got 643
billion of reserves abroad which they
can't convert into rubles so the central
bank is severely hampered as well as
various other uh sanctions that have
been brought in a number of companies
now leaving russia but to the point this
specific point around oil
i think nigel's right it is about 35 to
40 percent of oil and gas
or energy uh needs uh for europe but
it's higher than that for germany and
the problem is
that this strategy that the the european
countries have been pursuing of taking
their eyes off the ball for the last few
decades now of over reliance on russia
for energy security issues is now coming
to pass and it's easier said than done
it's fine for the us
to lead the charge on this but they're
not dependent on russian oil uh to heat
their homes or russian gas indeed uh
unfortunately europe are certainly in
the uk uh nigel makes a valid point that
we're not as exposed but europe is
really uh in my view not particularly
well equipped for this oil storage
capacity is not sufficient
you've still got a necessity to heat
homes until the spring uh from russian
gas as well you've got
at the moment the oil price is a hundred
dollars a barrel above a hundred dollars
a barrel you've also got the gas price
five-fold increase in the last year
it would potentially increase another 50
percent and you've already got pain here
that we're feeling with the um the
energy uh the price cap and the actions
the chancellor has taken to try and help
families now is the chance they're gonna
have to help an additional help on the
back of these price increases we'll have
to see it could we could be seeing
energy bills go up to three thousand
pounds potentially here so it look it
it's an important step in the right
direction but i think it's easier said
than done
nigel do you think ali is right in that
that we are going to have to take a hit
here ourselves obviously uh that the
move is to try and and [ __ ] the
russian economy but but we're also going
to suffer
in doing that
yes we are and even though that there's
only a sort of a small amount of it
of russian energy coming into britain
i'm you're still looking at predictions
of another um thousand pounds on average
on home energy bills
and on top of the rise that we've
already got coming through i mean mine
came through with a an extra thousand
pounds already
it we are that um this is something that
we're all going to have to deal with now
what is important is that the government
actually addresses the cost of living
crisis
on the basis that we all have to take a
hit it'll cost us as individuals to
support ukraine but equally it must be a
matter for businesses also
uh to shell out a bit and for the
government to make things a little bit
easier
they could do that with uh scrapping say
vat
on energy bills i mean there are that
there are a number of measures they can
take but yes it is going to be a bit
painful
and uh ali you mentioned some of the
other moves um to actually get get a
grip on that uh russian
economy and so that they feel some pain
we've broadcast tonight about price
waterhouse cooper withdrawing from
russia vtb banker prepared to wind down
its european operations as well
and um i think burberry closing their
three stores in in russia those sorts of
moves do you think that they are going
to have the real impact and hit russia
where it hurts
well i do think they are going to have
an impact but the key thing jillian is
that they've been no real sanctions yet
on the energy sector just to the point
that we were just discussing and the
reason for that is and there are also no
sanctions on spur bank which is the
largest russian bank because these
trades need to be settled uh through a
system so europe needs to pay for its
energy back to that old conundrum again
so this whole philosophy that
particularly the germans had for the
last 30 years on their energy policy
which was
vandal dorkhandle or or change through
trade has failed
the russians have not changed yes these
uh sanctions are going to have an impact
but also bear in mind another thing that
since the invasion of crimea in 2014
vladimir putin has been trying to
insulate his economy as best he can from
interconnectedness with the world
economy and to try and minimize the
impact of sanctions now he may not have
uh predicted that the sanctions would be
as swift and as severe as they have been
but certainly he's been trying to make
his own economy more robust to that
and also if there are further sanctions
coming even if they are imposed in the
energy sector which i think is highly
unlikely the reasons i mentioned
a lot of that will go to china
potentially that has got a voracious
appetite for energy so yes i do think
there is an impact i think they've been
swift i think they've been wide-ranging
all very welcome but i think vladimir
putin's got the stomach for this to run
and run and i think just economic pain
is not going to be sufficient enough for
him to change course but we'll have to
see
uh nigel let's move on to the daily mail
and they're quoting uk defense chief um
saying that
putin's victory isn't inevitable they've
taken quite a hit in his tactics thus
far perhaps haven't been perhaps as
successful as he thought they might be
yes this is admiral tony radekin who's
the the uh the chief of the defense
staff so he's our um britain's top
military man
and i i mean this is actually quite a
hopeful idea that in fact that the
ukrainians might be able to resist
and what he's suggesting is they could
even win that um the mail reports that
um uh today eight russian aircraft have
been shot down
uh which shows they don't have complete
control of the skies
i mean the only thing i would say is
that um i might be a bit of an armchair
general rather than a real one
but just looking at this and looking at
the at it from a political point of view
the one thing i can't see is how
um
vladimir putin can actually lose
that having taken the decision to go
into ukraine
there is no way that he can really come
out of it without victory
and so uh it may be that we end we end
up with more atrocities that um uh he
will use more extreme methods
but it does seem to be very difficult he
can actually
in any way pull away
and so on that basis then it's actually
down to putin himself
and really um the only way i can see
that ukraine can be saved is for
vladimir putin to go but that's a matter
for
uh for the the um uh the russian people
and more particularly the he the
military and the intelligence chiefs
surrounding putin at the moment
ali do you agree with with nigel that um
seemingly at the moment there there is
no way that uh putin can lose or do you
believe like um that affecting something
like a no-fly zone could tip tip the
balance
well look i i think julian has two
points firstly there's been a lot of
reporting in the last 11 days or so that
uh things are not going according to
plan for vladimir putin now that may or
may not be the case i i'm not convinced
that it wholly is actually i mean
he's trying to take over a country of 40
million people and it's been little over
a week i mean what do we expect uh putin
has got the stomach for a very long
fight here so i think over playing this
and saying that uh he's encountering
resistance
look it's clear that uh the ukrainians
are resisting and president zielinski is
being very brave and courageous and
leading his people in this fight and
they're all stepping up
and trying to resist which we we applaud
them we understand um but i think you
you are facing the the might of a
million strong army with a with an air
force and with
with
munitions
and arsenal of munitions which is how
far outweighs ukraine even with western
support so i think the no-fly zone uh
issue uh julian has also been talked
about zielinski's call for it again
and the argument being made by zielinski
is that the west the west is saying it
doesn't want to engage in hand-to-hand
combat uh directly well it's already
involved in the war because it's
supplying weapons to ukraine and that's
something that vladimir putin himself
has said that by supplying weapons and
by imposing economic sanctions the west
is already engaged in an act of war
which makes zelinski's point for him the
reality however is that there is no
appetite against stoltenberg the general
secretary of nato came out again today
and said this there is no appetite on
the part of western powers in nato to
engage in a direct combat potentially
with russia because that would lead to a
conflagration which could involve
multiple countries and thousands more
lives being lost so there is no appetite
at the moment what there is however is
some discussion going on with the us to
try and provide um
new uh airplanes to poland so that
poland can give its older airplanes the
migs to the ukrainian air force you know
how to use them there is a conversation
apparently going on around that okay ali
and nigel for the moment uh thank you
we're going to take a break coming up
more of tomorrow's front pages including
this in the telegraph barbaric putin
reigns down
terror
do stay with us
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me columnist at the
article ali mirage and political editor
at the sunday mirror nigel nelson um
let's uh kick this section off with
looking at the the metro um and uh the
the article the front page there
pointing to the fact that vladimir putin
is not uh playing by the rules despite
his insistence that he isn't targeting
civilians the evidence is otherwise
nigel
yes that's absolutely right and i think
that we've just been talking about
sanctions and military strategy
but uh this front page is actually
showing uh the most important thing of
all and that's the the awful human cost
of this war
so their main picture which is repeated
elsewhere in other papers is a of a
mother and child fleeing opinion uh and
it seems that that uh although the
russians keep saying that they're
calling ceasefires they don't actually
uh cease firing
so this is this is where we're actually
trying to remember the people who are
suffering
um and that's why i think that we must
keep the focus as much as possible on
the ukrainian people themselves and all
they're actually going through
and the photo there
actually um a
family that that's been struck down as
they were trying to to flee quite
distressing
ali
yeah i mean uh julian is horrific uh i
mean you've got a situation here where
the the norms of uh
a a battle are just being ignored
i mean you normally would have a
situation here which has been called for
by the un and others for humanitarian
corridors to be established to get
people out of centers like uh pin and
mario pole and you've got
a situation where in within minutes of
that uh decision being made about
humanitarian corridors you have people
being killed
uh and including kids and it's
absolutely heart-wrenching to see that
and then you've also got 1.5 million
people on the move right now the uh
the head of the uh un commissioner on
refugees is saying this is the biggest
movement uh since the end of the second
world war a lot of those people are
going to poland and to neighboring
countries
and you see
on the other side of humanity the good
side of humanity where polls who by the
way have taken a lot of criticism in
recent years for not being that
welcoming to migrants particularly from
certain parts of the middle east are now
opening their homes going and going to
the border
to collect people with their own hands
and invite them into their homes and
take care of them that is the positive
side of humanity and all of this yes and
poland saying tonight actually that
number's increased to to a million
they've confirmed they've taken uh into
the the country in the telegraph moving
on nigel and boris johnson's quoted as
saying that uh putin has launched a
sordid campaign of war crimes against
ukrainian civilians
that is what is happening isn't it war
crimes are being committed
well that's what that's what we're
seeing seeing on your on all your sort
of news broadcast at the moment that yes
that's exactly what's going on and one
of the things the telegraph is pointing
out is that lawyers for the
international criminal court and the
united nations they reckon they now have
have evidence of thousands of war crimes
and we're only 11 days
11 days into this war
the question of course is um who will
actually pay for that that there's
obviously no way of getting uh putin to
the hague to actually answer uh for this
uh unless he's deposed so uh it's
important to collect the evidence it's
important to make the accusations
what at the end of all this and let's
hope that the end is coming soon rather
than broken later nigel we must leave it
there thank you see in the next hour
both